Hey, everybody. Ira Glass here. So here at our program, during these weeks of protests and sorrow in the wake of the killing of George Floyd, we thought that today, we would offer a different way of thinking about where we are and where we might be going, and we would rerun our show about Afrofuturism, which is a way of looking at the harsh realities of the present that at least has a little hope built in.
大家好，我是艾拉·格拉斯。在乔治·弗洛伊德遇害引发的一系列抗议与悲痛中，我们节目组在思考，此时此刻我们身在何处，未来又将走向何方。我们决定换个角度看待当下，重播这期关于“非洲未来主义”（Afrofuturism）的节目。这是一种审视现实严酷困境的方式，并从中构建出一丝希望。
We first ran the show right after a very different kind of violence and very different protesters than we're seeing today. This is back in the summer of 2017, just one week after white nationalists with torches marched in Charlottesville and a white supremacist deliberately rammed his car into a crowd, killing a woman named Heather Heyer. This is in all of our heads as we made the episode you're about to hear, all of us wanting to feel some shred of hope. So here is that original show from 2017. It's This American Life from WBEZ Chicago.
这期节目首播于2017年夏天，当时的情况与今天截然不同，面临着不同性质的暴力和抗议。那是在白人至上主义者举着火把在夏洛茨维尔游行，并故意开车冲撞人群、导致希瑟·海耶死亡的一周后。我们在制作这期节目时，这些画面一直萦绕在我们心头，我们都渴望感受到哪怕是一丁点的希望。下面就是2017年的那期节目，来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。
OK, give me a level.
好了，给我测一下音量。
This is me, about how much-- how loud I talk.
这就是我的声音，大概是这个音量。
Not long ago, one of my co-workers here at the radio show, Neil Drumming and I took a field trip to Philadelphia.
不久前，我和我们电台的一位同事尼尔·德拉明一起去费城做了一次实地考察。
We're going to Amalgam Comics and Coffee.
我们要去的是Amalgam漫画咖啡馆。
It's a comic shop.
那是一家漫画店。
It's a comic book store, yeah, and also like a coffee shop.
是家漫画书店，没错，也是一家咖啡馆。
No, no, I got that from the name.
不，不，我从店名就看出来了。
[CHUCKLES] Yes, but it's I think the first comic book store owned by a black woman on the East Coast.
[轻笑] 是的，但我认为这是东海岸第一家由黑人女性拥有的漫画书店。
On the East Coast, we have to add that?
在东海岸，我们必须加上这个限定词吗？
I think we do.
我想我们必须得加上。
We're here because recently Neil's gotten really interested in Afrofuturism, and there's this whole intersection between Afrofuturism and comic books. The founder of something called the Afrofuturism Network is speaking at this comic store on this particular day. And what exactly is Afrofuturism? Neil's been prepping for this question.
我们来这儿是因为最近尼尔对“非洲未来主义”产生了浓厚的兴趣，而非洲未来主义与漫画书之间有着千丝万缕的联系。今天，有一个名为“非洲未来主义网络”的组织的创始人将在这家漫画店进行演讲。那么，到底什么是非洲未来主义？尼尔已经为这个问题准备很久了。
I don't know. There's, like, a long-winded academic Wikipedia explanation which I've never even been able to internalize or remember, honestly, if we're being honest. What I like about Afrofuturism, it just seems very-- it's this way of talking about black people in a way that's really hopeful.
我不知道。维基百科上有一大段长篇大论的学术解释，说实话，我从来都没能真正理解或记住它。我喜欢非洲未来主义的原因是，它看起来非常……它以一种真正充满希望的方式来谈论黑人。
It's this idea that we would be engaged in the same kinds of things that science fiction writers have always talked about. That we would be engaged with technology, that we would have a future in space, that we would master time travel, that we would have a future in utopian or dystopian landscapes. It's like--
这是一种理念，即我们将参与科幻小说作家们一直谈论的那些事情。我们将投身于技术，我们在太空中有未来，我们将掌握时间旅行，我们将在乌托邦或反乌托邦的景观中拥有未来。它就像是……
So probably, this is about science fiction. That's really just the tip of the iceberg. And the science fiction part is meaningful because, while there've been black characters in sci-fi for a while now, they're almost never the protagonists. They're never the ones driving the action. And for so long, in so many imaginings of the future, in so much science fiction, there were no black people at all.
所以这可能与科幻小说有关。但这真的只是冰山一角。科幻这一部分之所以有意义，是因为虽然科幻作品中已经有一段时间出现黑人角色了，但他们几乎从来不是主角，从来不是推动情节发展的人。在很长一段时间里，在对未来的各种想象中，在太多的科幻作品里，根本就没有黑人。
Which, as Neil points out, makes no sense. He says you can tell black people are going to make it into the future because they've survived so much already over the centuries.
正如尼尔指出的那样，这完全没道理。他说你可以看出黑人注定会走向未来，因为几个世纪以来他们已经在那么多艰难困苦中生存下来了。
One of the things that's really specific about Afrofuturism that I like is that it takes in account the past, in a lot of ways. It imagines that black people forms of survival, through the slave trade, through persecution, that that's almost a technology in itself, the ways in which we've come through those things.
我喜欢非洲未来主义的一点是，它在很多方面都考虑到了过去。它想象黑人通过奴隶贸易、通过迫害所形成的生存方式，本身几乎就是一种技术，我们就是通过这些方式走到了今天。
Oh, I see. The survival skills.
哦，我明白了。是指生存技能。
Yeah. And that everything that's been a part of our culture has made it possible for us to pave the way for the future. That's the thing that I like about it, I think. The feeling like, despite whatever trials or travails you've come through, that you will exist in the future. That just kind of makes me-- it makes me love being black. It makes me feel, like, what I love about being black. Like, oh, yeah. You know, we can get through this.
是的。我们文化中的一切都使我们能够为未来铺平道路。我想这就是我喜欢它的原因。那种感觉就像，无论你经历了什么样的磨难与挫折，你都会存在于未来。这让我……这让我热爱身为黑人的身份。它让我感觉到，身为黑人最棒的部分。就像是，噢，是的，你知道，我们可以渡过难关。
Things we've known about forever, Neil says are now called Afrofuturism. Old school stuff, like Parliament Funkadelic's pimped-out, trippy rides to outer space, which predates the term by 20 years.
尼尔说，我们一直知道的事情现在被称为“非洲未来主义”。比如像Parliament Funkadelic那种充满颓废、迷幻色彩的太空旅行音乐，比这个术语的出现早了20年。
[MUSIC - "MOTHERSHIP CONNECTION" BY PARLIAMENT FUNKADELICS]
[音乐 - Parliament Funkadelics 的 "MOTHERSHIP CONNECTION"]
Starchild, citizens of the universe, recording angels, we have returned to claim the pyramids. Party on the mothership. I am the mothership connection.
星之子，宇宙的公民，记录天使，我们已经归来，夺回金字塔。在母舰上狂欢吧。我是母舰联络人。
Lately, you see lots of famous black people excited about Afrofuturism. Rihanna and Solange appear in black space age fashion. The director of Selma and 13th, Ava DuVernay, is making a TV series based on a novel by the woman who's kind of a godmother to the movement, sci-fi writer Octavia Butler. That's after DuVernay finishes the science fiction classic A Wrinkle in Time with black actors in some of the leads.
最近，你会看到许多著名的黑人对非洲未来主义感到兴奋。蕾哈娜和索兰格穿着黑色太空时代的时尚服饰亮相。《塞尔玛》和《第13修正案》的导演艾娃·杜威内正在拍摄一部电视剧，改编自科幻作家奥克塔维娅·巴特勒的小说，她可以算是这场运动的教母。在那之后，杜威内还将完成科幻经典《时间的皱折》，其中一些主角将由黑人演员担任。
And then there's Marvel making Black Panther into a big mainstream movie. Then we'll go over to the Childish Gambino album that was a tribute to Parliament Funkadelic. And Janelle Monae's tour a couple years ago was a whole sci-fi stage show with men in lab coats, a story about androids. She sings about spaceships.
还有漫威将《黑豹》拍成了一部主流大片。再看看Childish Gambino那张向Parliament Funkadelic致敬的专辑。还有加奈儿·梦奈几年前的巡演，那是一场完整的科幻舞台秀，有穿着白大褂的男人，还有一个关于机器人的故事。她歌唱着宇宙飞船。
[MUSIC - "ELECTRIC LADY" BY JANELLE MONAE]
[音乐 - 加奈儿·梦奈 的 "ELECTRIC LADY"]
Ooh, I'll re-program your mind. Come on, get in. My spaceship leaves at 10. Oh!
噢，我会重新编写你的思想。来吧，进来。我的飞船10点出发。噢！
And comics. Neil and I were in Philadelphia for comics, after all. The thing that Neil was most excited to see in the comic book store was the new Iron Man, where-- I don't know if you heard this-- in the comics, Tony Stark is in a coma, replaced by a black teenage girl genius.
还有漫画。毕竟我和尼尔去费城就是为了漫画。尼尔在漫画店里最兴奋看到的就是新的《钢铁侠》，在那——我不知道你听说了没有——漫画里托尼·斯塔克昏迷了，被一位黑人天才少女取代。
And she invents a suit that's comparable to Tony Stark's Iron Man suit, which is, like, my favorite piece of fictional technology, anyway.
她发明了一套可以媲美托尼·斯塔克钢铁侠战甲的装备，这本来就是我最喜欢的虚构科技。
As he points out, replacing Tony Stark with a black teenage girl, that pierces right into the arc reactor heart of the techno superhero sci-fi pantheon.
正如他指出的，用一个黑人少女取代托尼·斯塔克，直接击中了科技超级英雄科幻万神殿的反应堆心脏。
I mean, think about who Tony Stark, the original Iron Man is. He's a wealthy white man. He's like, a millionaire white guy. He's the unattainable. It's great to have, like, a robot suit and save the world, but how do most people imagine themselves in that context? Whereas this girl, her education takes her to this place that a billionaire once was at. I mean, that's inspiring. It's moving.
我是说，想想原本的钢铁侠托尼·斯塔克是谁。他是一个富有的白人，一个百万富翁。他是遥不可及的。拥有一套机器人战甲并拯救世界固然很棒，但大多数人在这种语境下会如何想象自己？而这个女孩，她的教育把她带到了亿万富翁曾经达到的高度。那是鼓舞人心的，是感人的。
I don't know, maybe I'm being-- I was thinking about it a lot, and why has my interest been sparked so much recently? I've always loved science fiction, but the idea of black people in science fiction appeals to me now because of that notion of telling your own story, because the way black people are talked about, it's often a bleak future and--
我不知道，也许我……我一直在思考这个问题，为什么我最近的兴趣如此浓厚？我一直很喜欢科幻小说，但黑人在科幻小说中的概念现在对我很有吸引力，因为那种讲述自己故事的理念。因为谈论黑人的方式通常是凄凉的未来，而且……
And a bleak present.
还有一个凄凉的现实。
Yeah, yeah. A bleak present and maybe no future at all, you know what I mean? And so think about-- if you're-- I don't know. Maybe not everyone feels this, but I've been watching-- there's just a lot of videos of terrible things happening to black people. It's literally like almost a genre. And there's gotta be a parallel narrative, you know what I mean? There's gotta be a parallel narrative. And I think for me, the parallel narrative is Afrofuturism.
是的，是的。一个凄凉的现实，甚至可能根本没有未来，你明白我的意思吗？所以想想……如果你是……我不知道。也许不是每个人都有这种感觉，但我一直在看……有很多关于黑人遭遇可怕事情的视频。这简直就像是一种流派。必须有一个平行的叙事，你明白我的意思吗？必须有一个平行的叙事。而对我来说，这个平行叙事就是非洲未来主义。
And so-- I don't know. It's a way of feeling like-- it's so hard for me to say this without laughing at myself, but it is genuinely hopeful. It's a way of feeling hope.
所以……我不知道。这是一种感觉……如果不嘲笑自己就说出这些话太难了，但它确实是发自内心的希望。这是一种感受希望的方式。
We sit on a curb way too long talking about this and finally head inside the comic book store. It's bright and spacious and smells great, like fresh coffee. Decked out in posters for Wonder Woman, and Spidey, and X-Men, and Moon Girl.
我们在路边坐了太久，讨论这些，最后走进了漫画书店。店里明亮宽敞，闻起来很香，就像新鲜的咖啡味。墙上装饰着神奇女侠、蜘蛛侠、X战警和月亮女孩的海报。
The store was busy because Afrofuturism enthusiast and author William Jones was there to give a lecture on the history of black people in comic books. He popped a slide of a comic book cover from the '60s onto a screen.
店里人头攒动，因为非洲未来主义爱好者兼作家威廉·琼斯正在那里举办关于黑人在漫画书历史中的讲座。他在屏幕上放映了一张60年代的漫画封面。
This is 1966. Now we have the introduction of the Black Panther, not affiliated with the political organization. And the reason why I say that is because Marvel Comics recognize that maybe people are going to think we support the Black Panther Party, so they briefly changed his name to the Black Leopard. It didn't last, and folks were not buying it.
这是1966年。现在我们迎来了黑豹的登场，它与那个政治组织无关。我之所以这么说，是因为漫威漫画意识到人们可能会认为我们在支持黑豹党，所以他们短暂地将他的名字改为了“黑豹”，但这没持续多久，而且人们并不买账。
Most of the crowd is black, and nearly every adult Neil and I talked to was familiar with the basic ideas and iconic figures of Afrofuturism, including the owner, Ariell Johnson, a super energetic 34. She and Neil talked about the subject for a while, and it became clear that for Neil, Afrofuturism's really about the future, but for Ariell, it's about the present. It's something she sees every day.
人群中大多是黑人，我和尼尔交谈的几乎每一位成年人都熟悉非洲未来主义的基本理念和标志性人物，包括店主阿丽尔·约翰逊，一位精力充沛的34岁女性。她和尼尔谈论了这个话题一会儿，很明显，对于尼尔来说，非洲未来主义确实是关于未来，但对于阿丽尔来说，它是关于现在。这是她每天都能看到的。
Black people today, black people who are alive and walking around, it's like, we are Afrofuturism. There's a quote that says, I am my ancestor's wildest dreams. And I think that's true. It's like, when we think about our history in this country, from when we were first brought here, and the condition that they were in, the freedoms that we have now, the things that we are working to accomplish and achieve, those are only things that they could have dreamed about in their wildest dreams.
今天的黑人，那些活着并在走动的黑人，就像是，我们就是非洲未来主义。有句名言说：“我是我祖先最狂野的梦想。”我认为那是真的。就像，当我们思考我们在国家的历史，从我们最初被带到这里时，他们所处的环境，我们现在拥有的自由，我们努力去实现和成就的事物，那些只是他们在最狂野的梦中才能梦到的事情。
They could not have imagined-- it's like, I own this store, you know what I mean? And so I am Afrofuturism. You are Afrofuturism. The fact that we're walking around, we're defying and challenging stereotypes and negative images.
他们无法想象——就像，我拥有这家店，你明白我的意思吗？所以我就是非洲未来主义。你也是非洲未来主义。我们正在走动，正在挑战刻板印象和负面形象，这一事实本身就是如此。
It's been a hard week for stereotypes and negative images, and it's been a brutal week for the past returning into the present and feeling like progress never comes. It's been a week where lots of us have wondered about the future in this country, where things are going. Against that, today, we pose another way to see the world.
这一周对刻板印象和负面形象来说很艰难，这一周过去回归现实，感觉进步永远不会到来，这让人感到残酷。这一周，我们很多人都在思考这个国家的未来，事情走向何方。与此相对，今天，我们提出了另一种看待世界的方式。
Another way to look at the future and the past that puts it in some context, and helps make sense of things, maybe gives a little hope. I'm joined in the studio right now by my colleague, Neil. Hello.
另一种看待未来和过去的方式，将其置于某种背景下，有助于理解事物，也许还能带来一点希望。现在，我的同事尼尔也加入了演播室。你好。
Hey.
嘿。
Hey. OK, so my thinking is-- well, our thinking is, since I know really very little about this, about Afrofuturism, and you know--
嘿。好的，我的想法是——嗯，我们的想法是，既然我对此，对非洲未来主义知之甚少，而你……
I think I know a little bit more. Quite a bit more.
我想我知道的多一点。多不少。
OK. So our plan is that I'm going to go away, at least till halfway through the show, and you will stick around?
好的。所以我们的计划是，我先离开，至少直到节目中段，而你留下来？
Yeah, no, I've been writing pieces and talking to people all over the country about this, so I feel like I have a little bit of a grasp on it.
是的，没问题，我一直在全国各地撰写文章并采访人们，所以我感觉我对它有了一些掌握。
OK. All right. So I'll see you halfway through. Till then, I'm going to throw some sci-fi here. You have the com.
好的。好吧。那我们中段见。在那之前，我要抛出一些科幻内容。指挥权交给你。
I appreciate that. All right. Stay with us.
我很感激。好的。请继续收听。
Act One, Metropolis Now. I started really puzzling over Afrofuturism a couple of years ago when I went to an Afrofuturism conference in New York. Up until that day, I'd mostly heard the term used to refer to musicians like Sun Ra or to science fiction by Samuel Delany or Colson Whitehead. But at this conference, they were Afrofuturist artists, designers, programmers, filmmakers, fashionistas, healers, yoginis. There was even a woman selling homemade hot pepper sauce in the lobby.
第一幕，现在的大都会。几年前，当我在纽约参加非洲未来主义会议时，我开始真正琢磨起这个概念。在那之前，我大多只听说过这个词被用来指代像孙·拉这样的音乐家，或者塞缪尔·德拉尼或科尔森·怀特黑德的科幻小说。但在那次会议上，有非洲未来主义艺术家、设计师、程序员、电影制作人、时尚达人、治疗师、瑜伽师。大厅里甚至还有一位女士在卖自制的辣椒酱。
I began to realize that Afrofuturism wasn't an art movement in the way that I thought of, like, Cubism or Impressionism. It wasn't static or rigidly defined. The people at this conference who were so liberally applying the word were doing so because they thought it made their work seem somehow more active and vital, but I didn't understand exactly how.
我开始意识到，非洲未来主义并不是我所认为的那种艺术运动，比如立体派或印象派。它不是静态的，也没有被严格定义。在会议上那些自由地使用这个词的人，是因为他们认为这让他们的工作看起来更具主动性和生命力，但我并不确切理解是如何做到的。
As the term became more ubiquitous and The New York Times used Afrofuturism to talk about Beyoncé's wardrobe changes, I was still trying to figure out the essence of the thing. Like, what makes something Afrofuturist?
随着这个词变得越来越普遍，《纽约时报》用非洲未来主义来谈论碧昂丝的服装变化，我依然试图弄清楚它的本质。比如，什么让某样东西成为非洲未来主义？
I called the woman who'd given the keynote address back at that conference in 2015, activist and writer Adrienne Maree Brown. Adrienne told me that if I wanted to see Afrofuturism that I should visit her hometown, Detroit, Michigan, a post-apocalyptic city, she'd said. The auto industry is nearly gone. The city's infrastructure is crumbling. Many people can't afford basic resources like water and light. It's like the setting for some dystopian sci-fi story.
我打电话给那位在2015年会议上发表主题演讲的女士，活动家兼作家阿德里安·玛丽·布朗。阿德里安告诉我，如果我想看非洲未来主义，就应该去她的家乡底特律，她说那是一座“后启示录”城市。汽车工业几乎消失了。城市基础设施正在崩溃。许多人负担不起水和电等基本资源。它就像是某种反乌托邦科幻故事的背景。
As soon as I started reading up on the place, I came across this headline in the Detroit Metro Times, "Inside Ingrid LaFleur's Afrofuturist Mayoral Campaign." Wow. There was a woman running for mayor of Detroit, and the basis of her platform wasn't socialism or libertarianism. It was Afrofuturism. So I flew out there to hang out with her. I got to hear her do some fundraising, give a speech, talk to some potential voters, and we drove around.
我刚开始阅读关于那个地方的内容，就看到了《底特律地铁时报》的头条新闻：“走进英格丽德·拉弗勒的非洲未来主义市长竞选”。哇。有一位女士在竞选底特律市长，而她纲领的基础不是社会主义或自由意志主义。而是非洲未来主义。所以我飞过去和她待了一段时间。我听了她筹款、发表演讲、与潜在选民交谈，我们还开车到处转了转。
And see all the different types of architecture here.
看到这里所有不同类型的建筑了吗。
Ingrid is striking, impeccably styled and glamorous, yet still very bohemian, with a shock of gray in her perfectly coiffed hair. She pointed out her favorite landmarks. We visited a compact urban farm where they make something edible called Afro-Jam. We rode past a spot in Detroit's North End, where George Clinton's band Parliament-Funkadelic played one of his most iconic albums.
英格丽德令人印象深刻，装扮无可挑剔，充满魅力，但又不失波西米亚风，完美的定型发中有一抹灰色。她指出了她最喜欢的地标。我们参观了一个紧凑的城市农场，他们制造了一种叫“Afro-Jam”的可食用食品。我们路过了底特律北端的一个地方，乔治·克林顿的乐队Parliament-Funkadelic在那里演奏了他最具标志性的专辑之一。
George Clinton did create the Mothership Connection in Detroit, and he performed it here on Oakland Avenue, which is the street that we're on right now.
乔治·克林顿确实在底特律创作了《母舰联络》，他就在我们现在所在的奥克兰大道上表演了它。
Taking a reporter around and bragging about your hometown is what you'd expect from anyone running for mayor, but it wasn't long before Ingrid the Afrofuturist showed up as well.
带着记者到处炫耀家乡是任何竞选市长的人都会做的事，但没过多久，身为非洲未来主义者的英格丽德也显露出来。
The mothership is this wonderful symbol of our future space. And for me, it's this reminder of this empowering future space that can-- the possibilities of that and how it's always present.
母舰是我们未来空间的奇妙象征。对我来说，这是对那个赋能的未来空间的提醒，那种可能性以及它总是存在的方式。
We were talking about stuff I knew. I grew up listening to Parliament records too and reading the comics on the album covers. I always thought it was cool, groundbreaking stuff. But when Ingrid talked about it, she scaled it up to something more grand and spiritual, and a little esoteric.
我们谈论的是我熟悉的东西。我从小也听Parliament的唱片，读专辑封面上的漫画。我一直认为那是很酷、开创性的东西。但当英格丽德谈论它时，她将其提升到了更宏大、更精神、甚至有点深奥的层面。
To be honest, I found her a bit difficult to follow on this and other topics. But with her enthusiasm, she was just fun to listen to. And anyway, I came to Detroit to find out about Afrofuturism, and here she was, someone super eager and ready to talk about it, whether or not what she said made sense to me.
说实话，在这个和其他话题上，我发现她有点难以琢磨。但凭着她的热情，听她说话很有趣。无论如何，我来底特律是为了了解非洲未来主义，而在这里，有个人非常渴望且准备好谈论它，不管她说的是否让我感到有意义。
But my orientation, even within Afrofuturism, has always been cosmic. I'm a cosmic person.
但我的定位，即使在非洲未来主义内部，也一直是宇宙性的。我是一个宇宙人。
Here she is discussing time.
现在她正在讨论时间。
Time can be defined in 20 million different ways. It can go diagonally up. It can go diagonally down, below our feet, just like in the universe, right?
时间可以用2000万种不同的方式来定义。它可以对角向上走。它可以对角向下，在我们脚下，就像在宇宙中一样，对吧？
And here she is on the subject of lunch.
这是她关于午餐的话题。
Pleasure has to resonate all through the future, through your movement, into your world. A pleasurable experience for me eating-wise would be eating a great green salad.
快乐必须在未来、在你的运动中、在你的世界里产生共鸣。对我来说，饮食方面的愉悦体验就是吃一份很棒的绿色沙拉。
I'm going to time travel a little myself here and let you know that Ingrid LaFleur did not win the primary. She never even got on the ballot officially. When I was there with the election rapidly approaching, she was still sorting out her policy points. She talked to me vaguely about reviving Detroit's creative economy to rival the glory days of Motown and about the city's litter problem.
我自己也要稍微穿越一下时间，告诉你英格丽德·拉弗勒没有赢得初选。她甚至从未正式进入选票名单。当我在那里、选举临近时，她还在整理她的政策要点。她模糊地跟我谈论复兴底特律的创意经济以媲美摩城唱片的辉煌岁月，以及城市的垃圾问题。
Two days before the primary, she published a more thorough plan that called for, among other things, a universal basic income for Detroiters paid partly in digital currency. I guess that's pretty futuristic. But at the heart of Ingrid's campaign was an idea that I found far more compelling than any specific policy she put forth.
初选前两天，她发布了一份更详尽的计划，其中包括为底特律市民提供部分以数字货币支付的普遍基本收入。我想那确实很具未来感。但在英格丽德竞选的核心，有一个想法比她提出的任何具体政策都更令我信服。
In her plan for Detroit, she writes, "In order to manifest true revitalization, we must consider the histories and oppressions of the Black American population. The foundation of every institution, government, police, education, the museum was built to silence, disallow, displace, and render powerless Black Americans. These institutions were never created for Black Americans to truly prosper. It's time for a new plan."
在她的底特律计划中，她写道：“为了实现真正的复兴，我们必须考虑非裔美国人口的历史和压迫。政府、警察、教育、博物馆等每个机构的基础都是为了压制、否定、流离失所和削弱非裔美国人。这些机构从来不是为了让非裔美国人真正繁荣而建立的。是时候制定一个新计划了。”
That's not something you hear from many politicians, but it makes sense here because Detroit is 80% Black. Fixing the city means fixing it for Black people. Ingrid sees Black Americans as the protagonist in the story of Detroit, its future and its past.
这不是你从许多政客那里听到的，但在这里是有道理的，因为底特律有80%的黑人。修复这座城市意味着为黑人修复它。英格丽德将非裔美国人视为底特律故事、未来和过去的主角。
When I was growing up, people loved to say it was like 110% Black. It was super Black. It was just Black.
我小时候，人们喜欢说这就像110%的黑。这超级黑。它就是黑。
This is the other thing about Ingrid. Maybe she's idealizing. I wouldn't know. But she carries a shining vision of Detroit's past with her everywhere she goes.
这是英格丽德的另一面。也许她是在美化。我不知道。但她带着对底特律过去闪耀的愿景，无论走到哪里都带着它。
We drove past vacant houses and empty lots. So much of Detroit is falling apart, neglected or abandoned. But underneath it all, she still sees a vibrant city populated with a thriving Black middle class.
我们开车经过空置的房屋和空地。底特律很大一部分正在分崩离析、被忽视或废弃。但在这一切之下，她依然看到一座充满活力的城市，居住着蓬勃发展的黑人中产阶级。
I grew up walking through this park at dusk. There would be people riding bikes, jogging, playing squash at dusk. Like, it's getting dark. And my mother and I, we felt completely comfortable and safe walking through these woods.
我小时候在黄昏时分走过这个公园。黄昏时分会有人骑自行车、慢跑、打壁球。就像，天色渐暗。我和我母亲在树林里散步，感到完全舒适和安全。
In the car, we talked about Afrofuturism. At one point, I told her about the conference that I'd been to and how by now I'd heard the word "Afrofuturism" used to describe everything from comic books to condiments. But it wasn't coming into focus for me. I was starting to wonder if it was just a term for putting a positive spin on anything a Black person has ever done or will ever do.
在车里，我们谈到了非洲未来主义。有一次，我告诉她我参加过的那个会议，以及我到现在为止听到的“非洲未来主义”这个词被用来描述从漫画书到调味品的一切。但我依然无法看清它。我开始怀疑，这是否只是一个给黑人曾经做过或将要做的任何事情加上正面色彩的术语。
Like, I was moved by the optimism that seems inherent in Afrofuturism.
比如，我被非洲未来主义固有的乐观情绪所感动。
Yes.
是的。
But I was also like, if it's everything, then what is the point of it?
但我也觉得，如果它涵盖一切，那它的意义何在？
But that is the point, imagining a more healthier present and future, and kind of recontextualizing the past so that it's empowering instead of victimizing. It's our way of not only surviving, but it's also a way of healing in the moment because there's constant traumas that we're dealing with, historical and present day. So it's a way of allowing ourselves to shapeshift, to accommodate whatever comes our way.
但那正是重点，想象一个更健康的现实和未来，并重新解读过去，使其赋能而不是受害。这不仅是我们生存的方式，也是当下治愈的方式，因为我们正在应对持续的创伤，无论是历史性的还是当代的。所以这是一种允许我们变形，以适应任何即将到来的事物的方式。
Ingrid eventually dropped me back at my hotel. Earlier, she'd given me a greasy brown bag containing a cookie, which I now finally got around to eating. It turned out to be the most delicious gluten-free cookie I'd ever tasted, but I was still feeling hungry and a bit confused by our conversation. Whatever bigger point she had been making about Afrofuturism, I was afraid that it had been lost on me.
英格丽德最终把我送回了酒店。早些时候，她给了我一个油腻的棕色纸袋，里面装着一块饼干，我终于有时间吃了。结果那是我吃过最美味的无麸质饼干，但我依然感到饥饿，而且对我们的谈话感到有些困惑。无论她关于非洲未来主义说了什么更宏大的观点，我恐怕都没有领会。
I went looking for a burger and a stiff drink to mull it over. At a bar, over bourbon, I met a guy that I'm going to call Sam, with dark skin and hints of gray in his sideburns that portrayed his boyish face. He was dressed for a night on the town-- light blazer, Burberry shirt, patterned silk scarf. I asked him and another patron, both Detroit residents, if they'd heard of Ingrid LaFleur for mayor. They hadn't.
我去找汉堡和烈酒来琢磨这件事。在酒吧里，喝着波本威士忌，我遇到了一个我称之为萨姆的人，皮肤黝黑，鬓角带着一丝灰白，衬托着他孩子气的脸庞。他为晚上的外出精心打扮——浅色西装外套、巴宝莉衬衫、丝绸印花围巾。我问他和另一位顾客，两位都是底特律居民，是否听说过英格丽德·拉弗勒竞选市长。他们没听说过。
When Sam got up to pay his check after we'd only been talking for a few minutes, he surprised me by asking if I wanted to go with him to check out some of the other spots around town. I wasn't dressed for it, and I'd left my recording equipment in my room, but what the hell? Sam said it was OK for me to describe what happened next.
当我们交谈了几分钟，萨姆起身去结账时，他让我感到惊讶，他问我是否想和他一起去看看城里的其他地方。我没穿那么正式，而且把录音设备留在了房间里，但管他呢？萨姆说描述接下来发生的事情是可以的。
Sam had a nice car, a Mercedes. It never cost him more than $10 to park it in a lot. He loved that about Detroit. Parking was so cheap.
萨姆有一辆好车，一辆奔驰。在停车场停车从来没花过超过10美元。他喜欢底特律这一点。停车太便宜了。
He'd moved here from New York some time in the late '90s and fallen hard for the city. As we drove, he talked up the real estate. He talked about his job and the IT business he ran out of his home. Things seemed to be going well.
他在90年代末从纽约搬到这里，深深地爱上了这座城市。当我们开车时，他谈到了房地产。他谈到了他的工作以及他在家里经营的IT业务。事情似乎进展得很顺利。
We met up with Sam's friend, Rick, a bald, bearded, alpha male type in a reddish leather jacket, and followed him in his new BMW to a place called The Griot. It was the type of establishment what's commonly referred to as grown and sexy. Rick ordered another round of bourbon and some wings, and flirted with the bartender.
我们见到了萨姆的朋友里克，一个秃顶、有胡子、阿尔法男类型的人，穿着红色皮夹克，跟随他那辆新宝马到了一个叫The Griot的地方。那是一种通常被称为“成熟又性感”的场所。里克又点了一轮波本威士忌和一些鸡翅，并调戏了服务员。
By now it was clear that these guys were looking to meet women. And that was weird because of this thing that Sam had told me earlier while we were in the car together. He'd said that not too long ago, his wife had gotten sick, and he'd taken care of her for a year. And then she died, leaving Sam and their teenage son with only each other.
到了这个时候，很明显这些家伙是想认识女性。这很奇怪，因为萨姆在车上和我交谈时说的事情。他说不久前，他的妻子病了，他照顾了她一年。然后她去世了，只留下了萨姆和他们的十几岁儿子相依为命。
Sam didn't actually want to be doing what we were doing tonight. This was, like, only his second time out as a single man. He didn't feel ready to meet women, to date, but he also felt like it was time. He couldn't wait forever. So he was doing what he felt like he had to do to move forward.
萨姆其实并不想做我们今晚在做的事。这对他来说，只是作为单身男人的第二次外出。他觉得没准备好去见女人、去约会，但他又觉得是时候了。他不能永远等待。所以他在做他觉得必须做的事情来继续前进。
Sam and Rick took me to a few different spots that night, but the one that I remember the most was a place called Floods. From the outside, it looked like a common family restaurant. I thought it was closed until we rounded the corner and saw the cluster of people leaving their cars with the valet.
萨姆和里克当晚带我去了几个不同的地方，但我记忆最深的是一家叫Floods的地方。从外面看，它看起来像一家普通的家庭餐厅。我以为它关门了，直到我们转过弯，看到一群人把车交给代客泊车离去。
Inside, Floods was huge. Sam said it was probably about 2,500 square feet. A massive bar separated two rooms. At one point, there was both a band and a DJ playing simultaneously.
在里面，Floods非常大。萨姆说大概有2500平方英尺。巨大的吧台隔开了两个房间。在一个时候，乐队和DJ同时在演奏。
And wall to wall, there were well-dressed, grown-up Black folks dancing and singing along to classic soul, funk, and R&B. It reminded me of how Ingrid had described the Detroit she grew up in and its thriving Black middle class. 110% Black, she'd said-- super Black, just Black. I'd been drinking all night, so yeah, I was already a little in my feelings. But I swear, I teared up at the sight of it all.
墙壁之间，穿着考究、成熟的黑人们在随着经典的灵魂乐、放克和R&B舞蹈和歌唱。这让我想起了英格丽德描述她成长的底特律及其蓬勃发展的黑人中产阶级。110%的黑，她说——超级黑，就是黑。我喝了一整晚，所以是的，我的情绪已经有点激动了。但我发誓，看着这一切，我流泪了。
Sam hadn't wanted to come to Floods at first because he thought too many people would recognize him. I think he didn't want to be judged for being out on the town after his wife's death. And when we walked in, he seemed a little uncomfortable. We split up for a while, and later he found me standing in a corner at the edge of the dance floor, mesmerized. He pulled out his phone and showed me the number he'd just gotten of a beautiful woman who'd walked in earlier and drawn quite a bit of attention.
萨姆起初不想来Floods，因为他以为会有太多人认出他。我想他不想因为妻子去世后出来游玩而受到评判。当我们走进去时，他看起来有点不舒服。我们分开了一会儿，后来他发现我站在舞池边缘的一个角落里，神情恍惚。他拿出手机，向我展示了他刚拿到的号码，是一个之前走进来并吸引了相当多注意力的美丽女人的。
Earlier in the day, Ingrid had said a bunch of Afrofuturist stuff to me about Detroit, shapeshifting, and reckoning with its past, and healing. I felt like I was seeing some smaller version of that now with Sam. Most days, he was probably just a guy in some pain, struggling to survive this very traumatic thing that happened. But tonight, in spite of that, Sam was imagining a better future and doing something about it.
那天早些时候，英格丽德对我说了很多关于底特律、变形、审视过去和治愈的非洲未来主义内容。我现在觉得在萨姆身上看到了缩小版的东西。大多数日子里，他可能只是一个痛苦的人，挣扎着从这种发生的极度创伤性事件中生存下来。但今晚，尽管如此，萨姆依然在想象一个更好的未来，并为此付诸行动。
He smiled, shouted some words of encouragement at me over the music, and waded back into the crowd. His spirits were up. His evening wasn't over.
他笑了，在音乐声中对我喊了一些鼓励的话，又走回人群中。他的精神振奋了。他的夜晚还没有结束。
Act Two, Past and Perfect. So there's this idea that occurs over and over in Afrofuturism that, summed up, basically says the past is always with us. It affects us. It has the power to make us stronger if we learn how to use it properly. Some West African cultures represent this idea with the image of what's called the Sankofa bird. It's a bird walking forward, but with its head looking backward, meaning no matter what, we carry the past with us into the future.
第二幕，过去与完美。非洲未来主义中反复出现一个理念，总结起来基本是说过去总是伴随着我们。它影响着我们。如果我们学会如何正确利用它，它就有能力让我们变得更强大。一些西非文化用被称为“桑科法”鸟的形象来代表这个理念。那是一只向前走的鸟，但头向后看，意味着无论如何，我们都带着过去进入未来。
In one of the most well-known Afrofuturist novels, Kindred by Octavia Butler, the main character finds herself traveling back and forth between her normal, contemporary life in the present, and the world of her ancestors in the Antebellum South, where she's treated like a slave. And the two time periods start to merge. That's fiction. Our next story is told by a woman who went through a version of that in real life.
在最著名的非洲未来主义小说之一，奥克塔维娅·巴特勒的《亲代》中，主角发现自己在正常的当代生活和她祖先所在的南北战争前南方世界之间来回穿梭，在那里她被当作奴隶对待。这两个时代开始融合。那是虚构作品。我们的下一个故事由一位在现实生活中经历过类似版本的人讲述。
When I graduated from NYU with a BA in drama and a mostly unplanned double major in anthropology, my mother asked me, what are you going to do with that, act in a museum? This seemed especially rude coming from a sociologist, but she had a point. For the first few years of my adult life, that's exactly what I did.
当我以戏剧学学士学位和未计划的人类学双学位从纽约大学毕业时，我母亲问我，你要用那个做什么，在博物馆演戏吗？作为一名社会学家，这听起来特别粗鲁，但她说的有道理。在我成年生活的最初几年，那正是我的所作所为。
During those years, Azie Dungey was living in her hometown, a suburb of Washington DC, working as an actor at night in plays for which she was paid almost nothing. And to make some extra cash for Christmas, she took a gig, time traveling to the least desirable job of the 18th century. She was a slave, or she played one anyway, performing for tourists at George Washington's estate, Mount Vernon, for weekend events called Mount Vernon by Candlelight.
那几年，阿齐·邓吉住在她的家乡，华盛顿特区郊区，晚上作为演员在报酬几乎为零的戏中演出。为了赚点额外的圣诞零用钱，她接了一个活，穿越到18世纪最不受欢迎的工作。她是一名奴隶，或者说扮演一名奴隶，在乔治·华盛顿的庄园——弗农山庄，为周末名为“烛光下的弗农山庄”的活动表演。
The halls of the mansion were decked for Christmas. Visitors would walk through, stopping in each room to meet a character and hear their monologue about the season. There was Mrs. Washington, beloved wife, Dr. James Craik, Washington's physician and best bud, Nellie Custis, sweet-natured granddaughter, and me, Caroline Branham, slave. I had a script that I used to talk about Caroline's life. It was short. Besides the odd "I'm a slave at Christmas too, a slave to my husband and kids" joke from 40-year-old white women, people were interested and respectful.
豪宅的大厅为圣诞节装饰得漂漂亮亮。游客们走过，在每个房间停留，遇见一个角色，听他们关于这个季节的独白。有华盛顿夫人，敬爱的妻子；詹姆斯·克雷克医生，华盛顿的医生和挚友；内莉·卡斯蒂斯，甜美的孙女；还有我，卡罗琳·布兰纳姆，奴隶。我有一份用来谈论卡罗琳生活的剧本。很短。除了40岁的白人女性偶尔会开“我也是圣诞节的奴隶，是我丈夫和孩子的奴隶”的玩笑外，人们都很感兴趣且尊重。
After Christmas, I decided to stay on the job. It started out fine. The winter weather meant the visitors were mostly local and relatively few. I enjoyed my daily walks on the tree-lined lanes, soft snow falling on my hooded mulberry-colored cape as I looked out at the stunning view of the Potomac River. And when it was too cold, I would stay in the library and read through musty old books and primary source letters and notations that helped me understand this distant world I inhabited and the woman I portrayed.
圣诞节后，我决定留下来。开始一切顺利。冬季的天气意味着游客大多是当地人，相对较少。我享受在树木林立的小径上进行日常散步，柔软的雪花落在戴着兜帽的桑葚色斗篷上，看着波托马克河的迷人景色。当天气太冷时，我就待在图书馆里，阅读发霉的旧书和初级来源的信件和笔记，这帮助我理解我居住的这个遥远世界以及我所扮演的女人。
I was Caroline Branham, a real woman who had been housemaid to Mrs. Washington. I studied Caroline's life and times for months. And every day when I put on a beautiful crimson dress with tiny yellow and green flowers, I became her. With each eyelet I laced on my corset, I felt myself get closer to her posture, how her body related to the world.
我是卡罗琳·布兰纳姆，一个真实存在过的女人，曾是华盛顿夫人的女仆。我研究了卡罗琳的生活和时代。每天穿上那件饰有微小黄绿色花朵的深红色漂亮裙子时，我就成了她。随着系在胸衣上的每一个扣眼，我感到自己越来越接近她的姿态，她的身体如何与世界相连。
With my hair pulled back in two large French braids under a bonnet, I sat on a bench and set my fingers to the work Caroline did-- rows of stitches on shirts and brightly colored embroidery. I could picture her laying down her head at night next to her husband, Peter, and their six children-- Wilson, Rachel, Jemima, Leanthe, Polly, and little Peter. I imagined how she hoped that one day they would wake up in a world better than the one she'd been given.
我的头发在帽子下扎成两个大大的法式辫子，我坐在长凳上，手指做着卡罗琳所做的工作——一排排的针脚和色彩鲜艳的刺绣。我能想象她晚上躺在丈夫彼得以及他们的六个孩子身边——威尔逊、雷切尔、杰米玛、利恩特、波莉和小彼得。我想象她如何希望有一天他们能在一个比她被给予的世界更好的世界中醒来。
Then spring came, and tourists from around the country started pouring into Mount Vernon. My job was to simply be available to the visitors, to talk to them and answer their questions as Caroline. This time, there was no script. And I realized pretty quickly that just being there, existing as a Black woman in that place, was a threat to the fantasy of a noble America. I was the stain on George Washington's white house.
然后春天到了，来自全国各地的游客开始涌入弗农山庄。我的工作只是简单地接待游客，以卡罗琳的身份与他们交谈并回答他们的问题。这一次，没有剧本。我很快意识到，仅仅待在那里，以黑人女性的身份存在于那个地方，就是对高尚美国幻想的威胁。我是乔治·华盛顿白宫上的污点。
And I watched them grapple with this right in front of me. Me, the least confrontational human being you'll ever meet. I mean, it took me till I was 25 years old to tell my mom I did not like her baked tofu smothered in Kraft barbecue sauce. Some people were so uncomfortable with me that they bumbled through the first random thing that came to their mind. You're a slave? Oh, OK. So are the vegetables in the garden real? Fake vegetables. This is an outdoor garden. They are literally coming out of the ground, and there is a man standing there watering them.
我看着他们在我就在面前时努力应对这一点。我，你见过最不具对抗性的人。我是说，直到我25岁时才告诉我妈我不喜欢她用卡夫烧烤酱炖的烤豆腐。有些人对我感到如此不适，以至于他们语无伦次地脱口而出脑子里的第一个随机念头。你是奴隶？噢，好吧。那么花园里的蔬菜是真的吗？假蔬菜。这是一个室外花园。它们真的从地里长出来，旁边还有个人在那里浇水。
Or they immediately asked questions with obvious answers that they just hadn't thought through. Why don't you go up to Massachusetts and go to school instead of being a slave, one person asked. Right, as soon as I can get rid of this very obvious brown skin, steal a horse and a map that I can't read, I will be on my way.
或者他们立即问一些有着明显答案的问题，只是他们没想过。为什么不去马萨诸塞州上学而不是做奴隶，有人问。对，只要我能摆脱这非常明显的棕色皮肤，偷一匹马和一张我看不懂的地图，我就能上路了。
Or they'd go into immediate denial mode, like the old woman who out of nowhere yelled at me, George Washington had no slaves. I said, yes, he did. She responded, no, he didn't. And this went on back and forth until her son got embarrassed and pulled her away.
或者他们立即进入否认模式，就像那位老太太毫无征兆地对我大喊，乔治·华盛顿没有奴隶。我说，有的，他有。她回答，不，他没有。这来来回回持续着，直到她儿子感到尴尬并把她拉开。
Or they offered another offense as some sort of defense. But the Irish were slaves too. OK, that's not really true. And what the hell does that have to do with me?
或者他们提供另一种冒犯作为某种辩护。但是爱尔兰人也是奴隶。好吧，那不是真的。而且那和我有什么关系？
And of course, there were those who would take the opportunity to teach me instead. You know, slavery was a good, industrious life where you got room and board for your work. Mm-hm, a one-room cabin they built themselves with eight people sleeping on a dirt floor and a bag of cornmeal every week-- room and board.
当然，还有那些抓住机会教导我的人。你知道，奴隶生活是一种勤劳的生活，你工作能得到吃住。嗯，他们自己盖的一间小屋，八个人睡在泥土地上，每周一袋玉米面——吃住。
It was just a bizarre situation to be in, playing Caroline. I'd be sitting next to Miss Nellie in the midst of her roleplay, who'd be going on and on about the lovely letters that her dear grand-papa, George Washington, had written her, or all the fancy soirées that she attended. We'd be in the greenhouse with a gorgeous garden outside on an estate that overlooked the Potomac.
扮演卡罗琳是一种极其奇怪的情况。我会坐在内莉小姐旁边，在她的角色扮演中，她会喋喋不休地谈论她敬爱的爷爷乔治·华盛顿写给她的可爱信件，或者是她参加的所有华丽派对。我们会在温室里，外面是华丽的花园，庄园俯瞰着波托马克河。
I'd literally hear white visitors sigh, listening to Miss Nellie read from her letters, full of nostalgia for this time long gone. They'd talk about how much simpler things were back then, how touching George Washington's letters were, what a fine man, and how lucky Miss Nellie was to live such a charming life. It was charming. I was charmed by it.
我真的会听到白人游客叹息，听着内莉小姐朗读她的信件，对那个遥远的时光充满怀旧。他们会谈论过去的事情是多么简单，乔治·华盛顿的信是多么感人，他是多么好的人，内莉小姐过着多么迷人的生活是多么幸运。这确实很迷人。我被它迷住了。
Then it'd be my turn. Here's what I talked about-- how my husband is rented from Mrs. Washington's relative and how he could be sent back at any time, how I go home to my cabin at night hoping that none of my children have been sold, that once my friend was whipped so bad her fingers were torn and she couldn't sew for three weeks-- all real stuff from Caroline Branham's life. One time, an old lady just walked up to me while I was talking, hugged me, whispered, "I'm sorry," and walked away. Another time, a man handed me a $20 bill. So I guess that was reparations.
然后轮到我了。这是我谈论的内容——我的丈夫是如何从华盛顿夫人的亲戚那里租来的，他随时可能被送回去；我晚上如何回到小屋，希望我的孩子们没有被卖掉；我曾经的朋友被鞭打得太重，手指撕裂，三周不能缝纫——全是来自卡罗琳·布兰纳姆生活的真实事件。有一次，一位老太太在我说话时直接走过来，抱住我，低声说，“我很抱歉”，然后走开了。另一次，一个人给了我一张20美元的钞票。所以我想那是赔偿。
In Caroline's day, there were typically no more than 10 white people who lived in the Washington household at any given time. Meanwhile, there were 316 slaves. And who was there to tell their story? Me. I was the only Black actor. So I felt like it was up to me to be all 316 people, to research them too, so I could talk about my friend the blacksmith or Delphi the wool spinner.
在卡罗琳的时代，华盛顿家中居住的白人通常不超过10人。与此同时，有316名奴隶。谁在那里讲述他们的故事？我。我是唯一的黑人演员。所以我感到必须由我来扮演这316人，也要研究他们，这样我才能谈论我的铁匠朋友或羊毛纺纱工德尔菲。
I learned so much about being a slave that to this day, there is space in my brain devoted to this information. Like, I can tell you how to shine silver with horse urine, which herbs to use to make your owner sick, but not kill her, how beating a slave and then dousing them with saltwater to disinfect the wounds was called pickling. Pickling-- I hate that I know that.
我学到了很多关于做奴隶的事，以至于直到今天，我大脑中依然有空间致力于这些信息。比如，我能告诉你如何用马尿擦亮银器，用什么草药能让你的主人病倒但又不会杀死她，以及殴打奴隶然后用盐水浸泡伤口消毒被称为“腌制”。腌制——我讨厌我知道这一点。
As my time at Mount Vernon went on, I began to notice there was something that would happen in particular with white men. It was like, almost despite themselves, they would act out the power dynamic from 1797. I can remember at least five times when a white man of a certain age sat on a bench way too close to me and said something like, I used to be into a black girl, back when I was young. Then he would pause, presumably waiting for my response. What am I supposed to say to that, exactly? Thank you?
随着我在弗农山庄时间的推移，我开始注意到有一些事情特别会发生在白人男性身上。就像，几乎是不由自主地，他们会演绎出1797年的权力动态。我记得至少有五次，一位一定年纪的白人坐在我身边，离得太近，说些类似的话，年轻时我喜欢过一个黑人女孩。然后他会停顿，大概在等我的反应。我到底该怎么回答那句话？谢谢？
Once, a man got physical. I was walking down the lane on a particularly hot and busy day when a tall, burly, white man grabbed my arm, pulled me towards him, and said, show me where you're branded. I was startled and could only get out the words, sir, I haven't been branded. And then he and his wife began laughing heartily. Well, you got it good up here. We're from South Carolina, and they branded them down there. Girl, you got it good.
有一次，一个人动手了。在一个特别炎热繁忙的日子里，我沿着小径走，一个高大、身材魁梧的白人抓住了我的胳膊，把我拉向他，说，让我看看你哪里被烙了印。我吓了一跳，只能挤出这句话，先生，我没有被烙印。然后他和他的妻子开始放声大笑。嗯，你在这里过得不错。我们来自南卡罗来纳州，他们在那里烙印。姑娘，你过得不错。
And then one time, one of the guys I work with, also in costume, wearing a tricorn hat, he and I were walking from the farm back to the mansion, and we decided to take the forest trail. We were having a nice, normal conversation when out of the blue he says, hey, let's re-enact a slave rape. You tear up your clothes a little bit and go running out of the forest screaming, and I'll follow behind you, pulling up my pants.
还有一次，我和一起工作的家伙，穿着三角帽，我们正从农场走回豪宅，决定走森林小径。我们正在进行正常的谈话，他突然说，嘿，让我们重演一次奴隶强奸。你把衣服撕破一点，尖叫着从森林里跑出来，我会跟在后面，提上裤子。
He laughed. I didn't say anything. I just sort of tittered. I [BLEEP] tittered. That's an old timey, fancy way of saying I laughed with the bastard. I laughed because I didn't know what else to do, because I felt completely and utterly powerless.
他笑了。我什么也没说。我只是咯咯笑。我[哔]咯咯笑了。那是一种古老、时髦的说法，意思是我和那个混蛋一起笑了。我笑了，因为我不知道还能做什么，因为我感到完全且彻底的无能为力。
I started calling in sick a lot because I was sick a lot. My stomach would twist and turn. I would sometimes get a choking feeling and cough as if to vomit, but nothing was there. I had terrible headaches, and I couldn't do anything but sleep. And one day, it occurred to me that Caroline felt this way too, this exact way.
我开始频繁请病假，因为我真的经常生病。我的胃扭曲翻转。有时我会有一种窒息的感觉，咳嗽得仿佛要呕吐，但什么也没有。我头痛得厉害，除了睡觉什么也做不了。有一天，我意识到卡罗琳也有这种感觉，一模一样的感觉。
The farm manager who oversaw slaves on the mansion house farm noted that Caroline, quote, "complained of a pain in her head and side," and had, quote, "a very dry bad cough." George Washington's friend, Dr. Craik, is recorded as having treated her for such bad stomach pains that he had to bleed her, give her stomach drops, and prescribed 20 pills for bowel obstruction. My job was to inhabit Caroline's life, but she started inhabiting mine.
负责监督豪宅农场奴隶的农场经理指出，卡罗琳引用“抱怨头痛和侧痛”，并且有引用“非常严重的干咳”。乔治·华盛顿的朋友克雷克医生被记录在案，曾为她治疗严重的胃痛，不得不为她放血、给胃药，并开了20粒用于肠梗阻的药丸。我的工作是进入卡罗琳的生活，但她开始进入我的生活。
I had this weird sensation that I was living in multiple time periods at once, like the Sankofa bird. I started seeing Mount Vernon everywhere in the modern world. An evolutionary psychologist wrote a blog post for Psychology Today, where he claimed that he'd objectively proved that Black women are the least attractive of all races of women with science. This happened in the year of our Lord 2011.
我有一种奇怪的感觉，我同时生活在多个时间段，就像桑科法鸟。我开始在现代世界随处看到弗农山庄。一位进化心理学家在《今日心理学》上写了一篇博客文章，他声称他客观地证明了黑人女性是所有种族女性中最没有吸引力的。这发生在我们2011年的主年里。
I saw this only a few days after reading Thomas Jefferson's Notes on the State of Virginia for work. Apparently Jefferson-- who, by the way, was known to have slaves with the lightest skin possible-- had come to the same conclusion about my race and gender over 200 years ago. He said that black men prefer white women, and black women are preferred by orangutans. Oh, so that's why I'm single.
我在为了工作阅读托马斯·杰斐逊的《弗吉尼亚纪事》几天后才看到这个。显然，杰斐逊——顺便提一下，他以拥有皮肤最浅的奴隶而闻名——在200多年前就已经得出关于我和我性别种族的相同结论。他说黑人男性更喜欢白人女性，而黑人女性更受猩猩青睐。噢，所以这就是我单身的原因。
Then, Trayvon Martin. I was watching the news one evening about a black boy harassed and pursued by a white Latino man who was convinced that he didn't belong in his neighborhood. And because of this compulsion, the innocent black boy ended up dead. My heart was in my gut.
然后是特雷翁·马丁。一天晚上，我看着新闻，一个黑人男孩被一个白人拉丁裔男子骚扰和追逐，那个人确信他不属于那个社区。因为这种执念，那个无辜的黑人男孩最终死了。我的心沉到了谷底。
The first thought that came into my head, he didn't have his pass. Pass? I shook it off. No, that can't be right.
我脑子里的第一个念头，他没有通行证。通行证？我摇了摇头。不，那不对。
When a slave left their plantation, they had to carry a pass from their master or overseer saying where they were going and when they were expected to return. Not having your pass, or your free papers if you were free, was dangerous. At any time, any white person could stop you and demand to see your pass. If you didn't produce it, you were thrown in jail. Having black skin alone was enough to make you suspicious, and a white stranger could be the judge and jury of your fate. Trayvon Martin didn't have his pass.
当奴隶离开种植园时，他们必须带着主子或监工开的通行证，说明他们去哪里以及预计什么时候回来。没有通行证，或者如果你是自由民却没有自由证明，是很危险的。任何时候，任何白人都可以拦截你并要求看你的通行证。如果你拿不出来，你就会被扔进监狱。单单有黑人皮肤就足以让你受人怀疑，白人陌生人可以是决定你命运的法官和陪审团。特雷翁·马丁没有通行证。
There's a thing white people say to black people all the time. I've had it said to me. Why don't you just get over it-- "it" being slavery and all historical oppression. Why don't you just get over it, they say. It's in the past.
白人经常对黑人说一句话。我听过别人对我这么说。为什么不放下它——“它”指奴隶制和所有历史压迫。为什么不放下它，他们说。那已经是过去了。
What I would say to white people in response is that you're not over the past. Every year, you flock from all over the country to Mount Vernon and other places like it-- to monuments, and museums, and reenactments. There's President's Day and the fireworks that blast over George Washington's house every 4th of July. There are the Confederate flags and statues of Robert E. Lee that you don't want taken down. No, I can't get over it, and neither can you. None of us can.
我会对白人说的是，你们并没有放下过去。每年，你们从全国各地蜂拥而至弗农山庄和其他类似的地方——纪念碑、博物馆和重演。有总统日，有每逢7月4日在那座华盛顿故居上空炸开的烟花。有你们不想撤下的邦联旗帜和罗伯特·李的雕像。不，我无法放下它，你们也一样。我们谁也放不下。
Azie Dungey. These days, she's co-executive producer on a new comedy from Lena Waithe called Twenties, and writing a book of essays about her experiences at Mount Vernon, called How I Survived the 18th Century.
阿齐·邓吉。这些天，她是莉娜·怀特新喜剧《二十多岁》的联合执行制片人，并正在写一本关于她在弗农山庄经历的散文集，书名是《我是如何在那18世纪生存下来的》。
Coming up, we warp from the past back to the future, to Daveed Diggs and an underwater world of tomorrow. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，我们将从过去 warp 回到未来，来到戴维德·迪格斯和明天的水下世界。节目在芝加哥公共广播电台继续播出，稍后见。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, we are in the future, which we first broadcast in 2017, a show inspired by Afrofuturism, which my co-worker Neil Drumming became interested in back then as a lens to view the future, the past, and the present.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的节目中，我们置身于未来，这是我们2017年首次播出的节目，灵感来源于非洲未来主义，我的同事尼尔·德拉明当时对它产生了兴趣，以此作为观察未来、过去和现在的镜头。
When we made this episode a few years ago, we named it after an album by the experimental jazz artist Sun Ra, We Are in the Future. And now here we are in the future, three years later. It does not look good here, and it feels even worse. In terrifying ways, it resembles the futures of so many dystopian sci-fi novels that I was once happy to think of as merely fiction. Still, even though this episode was created from hopefulness, pain, confusion, rage, they were all baked into it because that is the reality of being Black in America.
几年前我们制作这期节目时，以实验爵士艺术家孙·拉的专辑《We Are in the Future》命名。现在我们来到了未来，三年后。这里看起来不太好，感觉更糟。它以恐怖的方式，非常像我曾经很高兴认为是虚构的许多反乌托邦科幻小说的未来。尽管如此，即使这期节目本身就带有希望、痛苦、困惑、愤怒，它们都是根植于其中的，因为这就是身为美国黑人的现实。
Afrofuturism doesn't say that Black people won't still be fighting for rights, dignity, breath, even as private corporations are building rockets to send tourists into space. Afrofuturism just asserts that we will still be here then and that fight will still be in us. Here's a song by Sun Ra, a little bit of call and response. It's called "The Space Age Is Here to Stay."
非洲未来主义并没有说黑人不会继续争取权利、尊严、呼吸，即使私人公司正在制造火箭将游客送入太空。非洲未来主义只是主张我们到那时依然会存在，那场斗争依然会在我们体内。这是孙·拉的一首歌，一点点呼唤与回应。它叫《太空时代将持续下去》。
(SINGING) It's going to be like your ancestors said, even though they're cold and dead. The space age is here to stay. Space age is around to stay. Yeah, the space age is here to stay. Space age is here to stay.
（歌唱）它会像你们祖先说的那样，即使他们已经冰冷离世。太空时代将持续下去。太空时代将持续下去。是的，太空时代将持续下去。太空时代将持续下去。
Which brings us to Act Three.
这把我们带到了第三幕。
Act Three, The Black Sea.
第三幕，黑海。
So this one I know about. There's this hip hop group called CLPPNG. It's Bill Hutson, Jonathan Snipes, and Daveed Diggs, who, listeners might know-- Daveed Diggs is on the soundtrack to Hamilton. He plays Lafayette and Thomas Jefferson.
这个我知道。有一个嘻哈组合叫CLPPNG。成员有比尔·哈特森、乔纳森·斯奈普斯和戴维德·迪格斯，听众可能知道——戴维德·迪格斯在《汉密尔顿》原声带中。他饰演拉法耶特和托马斯·杰斐逊。
And we commissioned CLPPNG to write a sci-fi story for us, a song. And what they made was a tribute to a Detroit band from the '90s called Drexciya. And Drexciya had created this whole mythology in their band. And the mythology was based on the idea that pregnant African women on slave ships were sometimes thrown overboard. And Drexciya imagined that the babies survived and learned to live and thrive underwater, and that the babies founded a Black Atlantis under the sea.
我们委托CLPPNG为我们写一个科幻故事，一首歌。他们制作的是向90年代底特律乐队Drexciya致敬的作品。Drexciya在乐队中创造了整个神话。这个神话基于怀孕的非洲妇女在奴隶船上有时被扔进海里的想法。Drexciya想象婴儿存活了下来，并学会了在水下生活和繁衍，并在深海中建立了黑人亚特兰蒂斯。
And so in this song that CLPPNG wrote for us, the civilization under sea was living peacefully for centuries, unaware that humans were above on land until those of us who live on the surface, we intruded on their underwater civilization by firing seismic air cannons into their world, looking for oil. And then they kind of slowly over the course of the song, you'll hear they slowly rise to the surface, psyching up for a war. So you'll hear the air cannons. You'll hear them come to the surface. Anyway, you'll hear it all. Here's the song.
所以在这个CLPPNG为我们写的歌里，水下文明平静地生活了几个世纪，不知道人类在陆地上，直到我们这些住在地表的人，通过向他们的世界发射地震空气炮寻找石油，侵入了他们的水下文明。然后他们慢慢地在歌的进程中，你会听到他们慢慢上升到地表，为战争做准备。你会听到空气炮。你会听到他们来到地表。无论如何，你会听到这一切。这是这首歌。
[MUSIC - "THE DEEP" BY CLPPNG]
[音乐 - CLPPNG 的 "THE DEEP"]
Y'all remember how deep it go. Started from the bottom. Y'all remember how deep it go, for y'all had to come back. Deep.
你们都记得它有多深。从底部开始。你们都记得它有多深，因为你们必须回来。深。
Y'all remember when it used to be deep, so deep, so, so deep. Hey. When y'all swam up out your mama while your mama was asleep. So deep, so, so deep. Hey.
你们都记得它曾经有多深，那么深，那么，那么深。嘿。当你们在妈妈睡着时从妈妈肚子里游出来。那么深，那么，那么深。嘿。
And y'all remember when y'all had the dance floor lit. Dark. No two step. Deep. Y'all don't even sweat. Deep.
你们都记得你们曾经在舞池跳舞。黑暗。没有两步舞。深。你们甚至都不流汗。深。
As deep as it gets. Dreaming dead, sleeping, keeping time. Y'all heart beat. Deep. Y'all heart beat. Deep.
尽可能深。梦见死亡，睡觉，保持节奏。你们的心跳。深。你们的心跳。深。
And all the fishes had they eyes bugged out because y'all dancing underwater, and y'all don't get wet. And the dark smelled sweet. And y'all tails touched reef. Y'all feed off the bottom, but now y'all remember. Y'all remember. Y'all remember.
所有的鱼都瞪大了眼睛，因为你们在水下跳舞，而且你们不会湿。黑暗闻起来很甜。你们的尾巴触碰礁石。你们以底部为食，但现在你们记住了。你们记住了。你们记住了。
Pressure outside the vehicle, 832.2 bars.
车辆外压力，832.2巴。
Y'all remember when the deep got hot, when y'all moved on up, how y'all used to argue about the water getting warmer. Still, y'all loved a little bit of light up in the deep. So deep, so, so deep. Hey.
你们记得深海变热的时候吗，当你们向上移动时，你们曾经争论水变暖了。依然，你们喜欢在深处的一点光。那么深，那么，那么深。嘿。
Y'all remember saying how it couldn't be them two legs because y'all came from two-legs. And y'all mamas would have loved y'all if they could've breathed, but they wasn't ready for the deep. So deep, so, so deep. Hey.
你们记得说它不可能是那两条腿吗，因为你们来自两条腿。如果她们能呼吸，她们会爱你们，但她们还没准备好面对深海。那么深，那么，那么深。嘿。
Y'all remember when the first blast came. And the beat fell off. And the dreams got woke. And the light bent bad. And the fishes belly up. And them coral castles crumbled because they wasn't quite enough. And conversation used to break like the floor quake, like the bleached bones.
你们记得第一次爆炸来的时候。节奏掉了。梦想苏醒了。光线弯曲得很糟糕。鱼儿翻白。珊瑚城堡坍塌了，因为它们还不够。谈话曾经像地震、像漂白的骨头一样破碎。
And the finned friends fled from they home, but the blast wouldn't stop because they wanted black gold. And them no gills had to feel it because they couldn't be told. Y'all remember. Y'all remember.
鳍状朋友逃离了家园，但爆炸不会停止，因为他们想要黑金。没有鳃的家伙不得不感受到它，因为他们无法被告知。你们记住了。你们记住了。
Ocean salinity, 35 PSU. Water pH, 7.91.
海水盐度，35 PSU。水质pH，7.91。
Y'all remember when the regime change, that no please, no calm seas. Let the water rise-- so deep, so, so deep. Oil slick upon the sleeper was an awful thing to realize. If the two-legs want to wake the dead, they gon' have to bring more fire. Y'all is closer to the earth. So deep.
你们记得政权更迭时吗，没有请，没有平静的海面。让水上升——那么深，那么，那么深。石油浮在沉睡者上是意识到的一件可怕的事情。如果双腿想要唤醒死者，他们就得带来更多的火。你们更接近地球。那么深。
And y'all was talking how to get up in their heads and got to being real inspired. Circumstances of the birth has got you feeling like an army, better yet a navy. And they gone gave y'all the blessing. Now y'all going crazy. They live with green upon the surface, but they ain't deep.
你们在谈论如何进入他们的脑袋，变得非常受到启发。出生的环境让你们感觉像一支军队，更好说是海军。他们给了你们祝福。现在你们疯了。他们在地表活在绿色中，但他们不够深。
That pistol shrimp will knock a two-leg off his feet. Y'all perfecting the steam void to rip up they ships. They using sonar as second language. Y'all fluent with it.
那只枪虾会把双腿踢下地。你们正在完善蒸汽空洞来撕裂他们的船。他们使用声纳作为第二语言。你们流利地使用它。
And all the dreamers is woke now, but nightmares swim. But everybody hear that "bloop" know y'all coming for them. Y'all remember. Y'all remember.
所有的梦想家现在都醒了，但梦魇在游泳。但每个人听到那个“噗”声就知道你们来找他们了。你们记住了。你们记住了。
Surface water temperature, 308 Kelvin.
地表水温，308开尔文。
Y'all remember when the call went out. Hey. No deep, no more deep. Sunshine. Y'all remember when the call went out. Hey. No deep, no more deep. Sunshine.
你们记得呼唤发出的时候吗。嘿。没有深海，不再有深海。阳光。你们记得呼唤发出的时候吗。嘿。没有深海，不再有深海。阳光。
Y'all remember feeling wind upon your skin. No deep, no more deep. Sunshine. Y'all remember how it burned in the beginning. No deep. Ride on 'em. Ride on 'em. Ride on 'em.
你们记得感受皮肤上的风吗。没有深海，不再有深海。阳光。你们记得起初它有多灼热吗。没有深海。骑在他们身上。骑在他们身上。骑在他们身上。
Y'all remember seeing sun across the surface on the day that y'all first came up out the water. So, so deep. How the breaking of the surface showed the sky without a border, and the air is so much hotter. So, so deep.
你们记得在你们第一次从水里出来的那天，看到阳光掠过地表吗。那么，那么深。冲破地表如何展示出没有边界的天空，空气热得多。那么，那么深。
How the woke dreamer screamed and it rose tides. And the waves stretched up like a mountain high. And the no gills gasped, and they closed eyes. And they prayed to their gods, and they ask why.
醒着的梦想家如何尖叫，潮水上升。波浪像高山一样延伸。没有鳃的人喘着气，闭上眼睛。他们向他们的神祈祷，问为什么。
And then y'all cry too 'cause y'all recognize mama in the faces of the ones that y'all were terrorized. They were sisters and brothers. They were the babies born up out the water, not connected to each other, not in knowledge of the one drop. But they had to learn today.
然后你们也哭了，因为你们认出了在那些被你们恐吓的人脸上的妈妈。她们是姐妹和兄弟。她们是在水里出生的婴儿，没有彼此连接，不知道那一滴血。但她们今天必须学习。
Y'all had one shot. Let the sun burn today. Let them feel the dark even deeper today. Make a two-leg a believer today. Let them know that they done woke a sleeper from a sleep. So deep.
你们只有一次机会。让太阳今天燃烧。让他们今天感受黑暗更深一点。让双腿今天成为信徒。让他们知道他们唤醒了一个从沉睡中苏醒的沉睡者。那么深。
That y'all been dancing without any feet. So, so deep. Here's the nerve that they struck with a blast that they broke with a drill that they burnt with the gas.
你们一直在没有脚的情况下跳舞。那么，那么深。这就是他们用爆炸击中的神经，用钻头破坏的，用气体燃烧的。
Y'all remember. So deep. Sunshine. Ride on 'em. Y'all remember. So deep. Sunshine. Ride on 'em. Y'all remember. So deep. Sunshine. Ride on 'em. Y'all remember when y'all had to let 'em breathe. Ride on 'em. Hey.
你们记住了。那么深。阳光。骑在他们身上。你们记住了。那么深。阳光。骑在他们身上。你们记住了。那么深。阳光。骑在他们身上。你们记得你们必须让他们呼吸的时候吗。骑在他们身上。嘿。
Initiating tidal wave sequence-- uniform, Romeo, 030.
启动潮汐序列——统一，罗密欧，030。
Daveed Diggs with Bill Hutson and Jonathan Snipes are CLPPNG. This song, commissioned by our program when we first broadcast today's show, ended up on their album The Deep, which you can find with their other music at their website. Their website is their band's name, which is the word "clipping" without the vowels. clppng.com.
戴维德·迪格斯与比尔·哈特森和乔纳森·斯奈普斯是CLPPNG。这首歌在我们首次播出今天节目时受委托创作，最终出现在他们的专辑《The Deep》中，你可以在他们的网站上找到它以及他们的其他音乐。他们的网站是他们乐队的名字，即没有元音的词“clipping”。clppng.com。
Act Four, Childhood's End. Looking into Afrofuturism over the past few months, I found myself thinking about time and space a lot. Time, because so many of these stories involve people thinking about the past or the future, or seeing the past and the future in the here and now, and space because all of that time travel is cued by very specific places-- Detroit, or Mount Vernon, or Philadelphia, or wherever.
第四幕，童年的终结。在过去几个月里审视非洲未来主义，我发现自己一直在思考时间和空间。时间，因为这些故事中有许多涉及人们思考过去或未来，或者在此时此地看到过去和未来；空间，因为所有那些时间旅行都是由非常具体的地点触发的——底特律、弗农山庄、费城，或者其他地方。
During those same months, I also became sort of obsessed with these two videos that I saw on YouTube. I couldn't help connecting them in my mind, because for me they were both about a particularly precious intersection of time and space. The time is that period when children have left school for the day, but haven't yet made it home. And the space is that distance, however many blocks, however many miles it takes those kids to walk from one to the other. In other words, these two videos are about those moments when kids are out in the world on their own and the adults they bump into.
在那些相同的月份里，我也变得有点痴迷于我在YouTube上看到的这两个视频。我无法不在脑海中将它们联系起来，因为对我来说，它们都是关于时间和空间一个特别珍贵的交集。时间是孩子们放学后但还没到家的一段时期。空间是那些孩子从一个地方走到另一个地方所花费的距离，无论多少街区，多少英里。换句话说，这两个视频是关于孩子们独自在世界各地以及他们偶然遇到的成年人。
You may have seen the first video. It takes place in Atlantic City. Two black teenagers in sweatpants and sneakers are fighting in the middle of a residential street on their way home from school when a slightly older black Man, Ibn Ali Miller, emerges from camera right and puts an end to the fight with a stern but passionate talking to.
你可能看过第一个视频。它发生在大西洋城。两个穿着运动裤和运动鞋的黑人青少年在放学回家的路上在住宅街道中间打架，这时一个稍微年长点的黑人男人，伊本·阿里·米勒，从镜头右侧出现，用一番严厉但充满激情的话语结束了这场争斗。
The clip went viral. Miller was honored by the city. Steve Harvey had him on his couch. I saw it for the first time on my Facebook feed this past winter, and I viewed it on YouTube many times since. It does not disappoint. It gets better every time I watch it.
视频疯传。米勒受到了城市的表彰。史蒂夫·哈维请他上了节目。去年冬天我第一次在Facebook上看到它，从那以后我在YouTube上看了很多次。它没让人失望。每次看都觉得更好。
[KIDS TAUNTING, LAUGHING]
[孩子们嘲笑，大笑]
When it begins, the two boys grapple and flail at each other sloppily-- one tall, one chubby, both defiant. Other kids crowd around, recording with their cell phones, egging them on.
当它开始时，两个男孩笨拙地抓扯着对方——一个高个子，一个胖乎乎，都充满敌意。其他孩子围在周围，用手机录制，煽风点火。
Square up. Go ahead, [BLEEP] off him. [BLEEP].
对准。来啊，[哔]揍他。[哔]。
Then, seemingly out of nowhere, Miller bops into frame, his hands in his pockets, wearing work boots and a knit cap. He immediately starts to call out the kids who are recording.
然后，看似毫无征兆，米勒跳入画面，双手插兜，戴着工作靴和针织帽。他立即开始喊那些正在录制的孩子们。
Everybody on your phones though. Oh, y'all, y'all the real cowards. Record that, too. Everybody on a phone, record that. Everybody record on the phone real cowards.
不过大家都在用手机。噢，你们，你们是真正的懦夫。录下那个，也是。每个人都用手机，录下。每个人用手机录制真正的懦夫。
Cowards, Miller calls them. Then he turns his attention to the two boys in the center.
懦夫，米勒叫他们。然后他转向中间的两个男孩。
Listen, they all laughing, little brother. But you really upset. And you really upset. You more mad than he is. I can see it in your face. So you fighting for a reason. He only fighting you because you want to fight him.
听着，他们都在笑，小兄弟。但你真的很沮丧。你也真的很沮丧。你比他更愤怒。我从你脸上能看出来。所以你是为了理由而战。他只是因为你想打他才和你打。
No, he came to me. He touched me. I wasn't [BLEEP]. I don't even know.
不，他先来找我。他碰了我。我没[哔]。我甚至不知道。
So you're defending yourself?
所以你在自卫？
Miller listens. And then he tells the boys something they probably hadn't considered, that they were most likely tricked into fighting by someone who thought it would be entertaining. And now all of their so-called friends are recording them go at it.
米勒听着。然后他告诉男孩们一些他们可能没考虑过的事情，他们很可能是被某人诱骗去打架，那个人觉得这很有趣。现在他们所有所谓的“朋友”都在录下他们打斗。
Look around. Who ill-advised you? You told you wrong? Who told you wrong? You want to answer that? I'm saying, who told you wrong, little bro?
环顾四周。谁给你出了坏主意？谁告诉你错了？谁告诉你错了？你想回答吗？我说，谁告诉你错了，小兄弟？
And the only reason I'm saying this to all y'all, yo, because you're almost men. All of y'all, yo. You're almost men. Y'all ain't kids no more. Y'all girls ain't little girls no more. Look, yo. Y'all men, yo. Y'all men, yo. 14, 15, 16-- y'all men. Start acting like it, yo. We ain't gonna get nowhere like this, yo.
我之所以对你们所有人说这个，是因为你们快要成为男人了。你们所有人。你们不再是小孩子了。你们女孩不再是小女孩了。看，你们是男人。你们是男人。14岁、15岁、16岁——你们是男人。开始表现得像个男人。我们这样下去什么也得不到。
We ain't going to get nowhere like this, he says. Here, what Miller does that I love is steer the conversation away from personal grievances towards something bigger. He tries to tell these kids that they are part of a community. He tells them that their actions have consequences and that those consequences only get more serious as they get older. Without condescending to them, Miller talks to them about their futures.
我们这样下去什么也得不到，他说。米勒做得我喜欢的一点是，将谈话从个人恩怨引向更宏大的层面。他试图告诉这些孩子，他们是一个社区的一部分。他告诉他们，他们的行为有后果，而这些后果只会随着年龄增长变得更严重。米勒没有屈尊俯就，而是与他们谈论他们的未来。
You think it's a game out here? Ain't no game out here. It's real out here, little bro. Word up. Don't make your parents look like this, yo. If y'all live around here, y'all live somewhere good. Don't mess that up.
你觉得外面是游戏吗？外面可不是游戏。外面是现实，小兄弟。听着。别让你的父母看起来像这样。如果你们住在这儿附近，你们住在一个不错的地方。别把这一切搞砸了。
He's no longer just trying to get them to save face or avoid humiliation. He's warning the boys that as they become men, young black men, the world will become even more dangerous for them. Miller won't leave until the two shake hands. They don't want to at first. Only the chubby kid extends his hand.
他不再只是试图让他们保住面子或避免羞辱。他警告男孩们，当他们成为男人，年轻黑人男性时，世界对他们来说会变得更危险。米勒不离开直到两人握手。起初他们不想。只有胖乎乎的孩子伸出了手。
Y'all don't shake hands or I'm not leaving, bro. I'm not leaving, bro. Shake hands, bro.
你们如果不握手我就不离开，兄弟。我不离开，兄弟。握手，兄弟。
Just shake his hand, bro.
跟他握手，兄弟。
The other kid doesn't. The chubby kid pulls his hand back.
另一个孩子没动。胖乎乎的孩子缩回了手。
Put your hand back out, bro. He gonna shake it this time, I promise you. Put your hand back out, bro. He gonna shake it, bro.
把手伸出来，兄弟。我保证他这次会握手的。把手伸出来，兄弟。他会握手的，兄弟。
He does.
他握了。
It's actually difficult for me to express how moved I was by this video. The beauty of it is that even while Miller is insisting that these teenagers become responsible for themselves, his actions demonstrate that they're not necessarily alone, that there is compassion, and wisdom, and guidance available to them.
实际上我很难表达这个视频让我有多感动。它的美在于，即使米勒坚持要求这些青少年为自己负责，他的行为也证明他们不一定孤单，还有同情心、智慧和指导提供给他们。
It was like a window into a world where people who don't know each other still give a damn, a window that I could rewind, and re-watch, and forward to my friends to click Like. It was at once exhilarating and comforting. I rode that high for a week, maybe two.
这就像一扇窗户，看到一个人们即使不认识彼此也会互相关心的世界，一扇我可以倒带、重看并转发给朋友点赞的窗户。它既让人振奋又让人感到安慰。我那股兴奋劲持续了一周，也许两周。
Then another video popped up in my Facebook feed. This one is shakier and from a low angle, obviously recorded surreptitiously. The view is of the intersection of Bedford Avenue and Campus Road, Midwood High School on one side of the street. Brooklyn College is on the other. I recognized it immediately because I used to live 10 minutes away. There's still snow on the ground, and the cell phone is buffeted about by wind.
然后另一个视频出现在我的Facebook动态里。这个视频摇晃得厉害，从低角度拍摄，显然是偷偷录制的。视图是贝德福德大道和校园路的交汇处，一边是米德伍德高中。另一边是布鲁克林学院。我立即认了出来，因为我曾经住在10分钟路程外。地上还有积雪，手机被风吹得晃动。
Its camera wobbles up behind two uniformed police officers walking slowly down Campus Road. The one on the left has both hands in his pockets. The one on the right has his baton already drawn. A handful of black teenagers walk obstinately before them, headed away toward Flatbush Avenue.
镜头摇摇晃晃地跟在两个缓慢沿着校园路行走的穿制服警察身后。左边的那个双手插在口袋里。右边的那个警棍已经拔出来了。几个黑人青少年在他们前面固执地走着，朝弗拉特布什大道走去。
There's no way to know for sure what happened before the video started rolling. There were, most likely, the beginnings of a snowball fight, but it's unclear who was unhappy about that. The police were not called. They were already on site.
无法确切知道视频开始前发生了什么。很有可能，是一场打雪仗的开始，但不清楚是谁对此不满。警察没有被叫来。他们就在现场。
In the footage, one of the cops says, come on, let's go, though the kids are already going. The cop on the right reaches out. It looks like he shoves a boy in a pink hoodie. The boy flinches, snapping his head around.
在画面中，一名警察说，来吧，我们走吧，尽管孩子们已经在走了。右边的警察伸出手。看起来他推了一个穿着粉色连帽衫的男孩。男孩畏缩了一下，猛地转过头。
Stop touching me, he says. The cop responds with, what are you going to do about it, which is obnoxious and a stupid question. But that doesn't stop him from asking it at least five more times, like a kid taunting another kid.
别碰我，他说。警察回答，你想拿它怎么办，这既讨厌又是个愚蠢的问题。但这并没有阻止他至少再问五次，就像一个孩子在挑衅另一个孩子。
What are you going to do about it? What are you going to do about it? What are you going to do about it? What are you going to do about it? What are you going to do about it?
你想拿它怎么办？你想拿它怎么办？你想拿它怎么办？你想拿它怎么办？你想拿它怎么办？
At one point, one of the teenagers fires back, that's why we out. It sounds bad ass. But if you think about it, the kid is saying, we're walking away because we can't do anything about it. And we all know that. Another kid in the procession kneels down to pick up some snow. With his left hand, the cop on the right pulls his taser out of his holster and barks--
在一个时候，一个青少年回击道，这就是为什么我们要走。听起来很酷。但如果你想想，那个孩子在说，我们走开是因为我们什么也做不了。我们都知道这一点。行列里的另一个孩子弯下腰去捡雪。右边的警察左手掏出泰瑟枪，咆哮道——
Pick that [BLEEP] up again. Pick that [BLEEP] up again.
再捡那个[哔]东西试试。再捡那个[哔]东西试试。
Pick that [BLEEP] up again. Rock, paper, scissors, snowball, taser. The kids keep walking away. The cop yells, pick that [BLEEP] up again one more time, and follows with--
再捡那个[哔]东西试试。石头、剪子、布、雪球、泰瑟枪。孩子们继续走开。警察又吼了一次“再捡那个[哔]东西试试”，并接着说——
Do you want to ride the lightning?
你想体验闪电骑行吗？
Do you want to ride the lightning? The video ends as the kids cross the street to safety, and the cops stop on the corner. I know. I know it seems like you can see worse, more unjust things happen to black people on YouTube just about any day of the week. Here, fortunately, no one was hurt.
你想体验闪电骑行吗？视频结束时，孩子们穿过街道到达安全地带，警察停在拐角处。我知道。我知道这看起来好像你几乎每天都能在YouTube上看到更糟糕、更不公正的事情发生在黑人身上。在这里，幸运的是，没人受伤。
But this video was still hard to watch, especially having seen how Ibn Ali Miller talked those kids down in Atlantic City. Whereas Miller was trying to get the teenagers to think a little bit more like adults, the cop in this video sounded like a teenager himself, bullying and provoking. What's worse, he almost seemed to be enjoying it. It's hard to imagine he cared anything at all about what happened to those kids after they deserted that corner.
但这个视频依然很难看，尤其是看过伊本·阿里·米勒在大西洋城是怎么劝说那些孩子之后。米勒试图让青少年多像成年人一样思考，而视频里的警察听起来就像他自己是个青少年，霸凌和挑衅。更糟的是，他似乎很享受。很难想象他一点也不在乎那些孩子在离开那个拐角后发生了什么。
I told my friends about this video too. I sent the link around. It wasn't as popular a clip as the one with Miller. I read everything I could about it. I found out that the kids most likely went to Midwood High School.
我也告诉了朋友关于这个视频的事。我发了链接。它不如米勒那个视频受欢迎。我阅读了所有能找到的关于它的内容。我发现孩子们很可能是去米德伍德高中的。
And a few weeks later, I went to Midwood High School and stood on the corner of Bedford Avenue and Campus Road. I wanted to find someone who had witnessed the incident. I was angry on behalf of those young men, and I wanted to know how they felt. I found one of them immediately, and then the others found me.
几周后，我去了米德伍德高中，站在贝德福德大道和校园路的拐角处。我想找一个目击了事件的人。我为那些年轻人感到愤怒，我想知道他们的感受。我立即找到了其中一个，然后其他人也找到了我。
Wait, which one were you?
等等，你是哪一个？
Me? I was the Black kid.
我？我是那个黑人孩子。
Well, they were all Black kids.
好吧，他们都是黑人孩子。
I was the blackest one, the tallest one.
我是最黑的那个，最高的那个。
They're in tapered gray sweats and colorful knapsacks. They told me they came to this spot almost every day, bought chicken, and fries, and rice, slap boxed with each other, kicked it with girls, and waited for the rest of their crew to go play basketball down the block. They wanted to know what my microphone was for and if they could get money and girls from being on the radio, and if I could buy them lunch.
他们穿着紧身灰色运动裤，背着彩色背包。他们告诉我他们几乎每天都来这个地方，买炸鸡、薯条和米饭，互相打闹，和女孩们在一起，等待他们的队友去街区篮球场玩。他们想知道我的麦克风是干什么用的，如果是上广播能不能拿到钱和女孩，还有我能不能给他们买午餐。
I asked them what they were doing on the day that the video was recorded. One of them said he was cutting class. Others said they weren't. I asked them why they think the cops came, since their high school has its own security. One of them said that some other kids across the street were throwing snow and the cops thought it was us. One of the boys said it was them, but still, it was only snowballs.
我问他们视频录制那天在干什么。其中一个说他在逃课。其他人说没有。我问他们为什么认为警察会来，既然他们的高中有自己的保安。其中一个说对面的一些孩子在扔雪球，警察以为是我们。其中一个男孩说是他们，但无论如何，那只是雪球。
We were just being kids.
我们只是像个孩子。
Yeah, we was being kids, chilling.
是的，我们像个孩子，在那儿闲逛。
Yeah, and they were just wilding out.
是的，他们只是在发疯。
We was just having snowballs-- we was having a snowball fight.
我们只是在打雪仗。
Yeah, we were doing what we was doing. And we were just having fun.
是的，我们在做我们做的事。我们只是玩得很开心。
I asked if they were scared when it happened. A couple of 16-year-olds cooler than I'd ever been at that age said, no, not really. A 14-year-old said emphatically, of course. He was 6'2, my height.
我问他们发生那件事时害怕吗。几个比我在那个年纪酷得多的16岁孩子说，不，没怎么怕。一个14岁的孩子强调说，当然了。他6英尺2英寸，我的身高。
I was surprised at how tall some of the boys were, none of them older than 16. I was also surprised at how not angry they seemed. I grew up about 45 minutes from here in a similar neighborhood in Queens, not so long ago, I thought. But when I asked them why they thought this had happened to them at all, one of the older boys talked to me like he was explaining why humans need food. The cop was white.
我对一些男孩的身高感到惊讶，没人超过16岁。我也对他们似乎一点都不生气感到惊讶。我小时候离这儿大约45分钟路程，在皇后区一个类似的社区，没多久前，我想。但当我问他们为什么认为这会发生在他们身上时，其中一个大一点的男孩谈论我，就像在解释人类为什么需要食物。那个警察是白人。
You know, they don't like Black people. And I thought-- I was like, oh, we about to-- [IMITATES TASER]
你知道，他们不喜欢黑人。我想——我当时想，噢，我们要——[模仿泰瑟枪声]
Yeah, we about to get tased.
是的，我们要被电了。
Maybe this is just me, but I look back on walks home from school as my first real flirtations with independence, a sacred time and space between my teachers' rules and my parents' restrictions. The kids in that video, this was their school. This was their neighborhood.
也许这只是我，但回望放学回家的路，那是我第一次真正感受到独立的诱惑，那是我的老师规则和我父母限制之间一段神圣的时间和空间。那个视频里的孩子们，这是他们的学校。这是他们的社区。
Most of the ones I talked to live only four or five blocks away. As far as they were concerned, this was their corner. I can't imagine what it would feel like to be firmly in your time and space and run up against a cop with a taser, threatening to electrocute you if you don't put down that snowball.
我交谈的大多数人只住在四五个街区外。对他们而言，这是他们的角落。无法想象身为你在自己的时间和空间中，遇到一个拿着泰瑟枪的警察，威胁如果你不放下那个雪球就要电击你，会是什么感觉。
What's crazier to me is that I've walked through this intersection at Bedford Avenue and Campus Road, past the high school, and through the Brooklyn College campus many times in the last few years. Beneath its landmark gilded clock tower, Brooklyn College could be a campus quad from a corny 1950s film, except teeming with students from cultures all over New York. Something about it practically screams welcome, things only get better from here.
更让我疯狂的是，过去几年我多次走过贝德福德大道和校园路的这个路口，经过高中，穿过布鲁克林学院校园。在标志性的镀金钟楼下，布鲁克林学院可以是从一部老掉牙的1950年代电影中的校园广场，只是挤满了来自纽约各地文化的学生。它几乎在大声喊着欢迎，事情只会从这里变得更好。
The young Black men in that video came out of their high school that day and stood at the edge of that promise. What could be the next great space and time in their lives was a college literally across the street, but they were shooed away, told they didn't belong. As far as metaphors go, this one couldn't be less ambiguous.
视频里的年轻黑人男性那天走出高中，站在承诺的边缘。他们生命中下一个伟大的时间和空间可能就是街对面的学院，但他们被赶走了，被告知他们不属于这里。就隐喻而言，这一个再明显不过了。
But none of this seemed to bother the boys, or at least not that they let on. This was not the first time that they had been made to feel unwelcome so close to home and school, yet they weren't festering with resentment. They weren't seeing the tragedy in it that I was seeing.
但这些都没怎么困扰男孩们，至少他们没表现出来。这不是他们第一次在离家和学校这么近的地方感到不受欢迎，但他们并没有因为怨恨而腐烂。他们没有看到我所看到的悲剧。
After I finished talking to them, I went across the street to find the Brooklyn College professor who'd recorded the incident. Alex Vitale teaches sociology, and also happens to run the school's policing and social justice project. Leaving work that day, he'd seen the two cops descend on Bedford Avenue and Campus Road, followed them. And it was his recording that ended up on YouTube, as well as a few local news websites.
在和他们谈完后，我过马路去找录制这段视频的布鲁克林学院教授。亚历克斯·维塔莱教授社会学，也碰巧运营学校的警务和社会正义项目。那天离开工作岗位，他看到那两名警察冲向贝德福德大道和校园路，就跟了过去。正是他的录像最终出现在YouTube以及一些当地新闻网站上。
We talked briefly about how repeated incidents like this could affect the boys' psyches. He agreed that no matter how cool they seem now, over time their hopes for their own futures could possibly darken. But then Alex asked me how old I was. When I told him 43, he said that I had missed the height of the stop and frisk era. I was not a teenager or even a young man in New York City when unprompted police harassment was at its worst.
我们简单谈论了像这样反复发生的事件可能如何影响男孩们的心理。他同意无论他们现在看起来多酷，随着时间推移，他们对自己未来的希望可能会暗淡。但亚历克斯问我多大。当我告诉他43岁时，他说我错过了拦截盘查时代的高峰。当无缘无故的警察骚扰最严重时，我并不是纽约市的青少年或年轻人。
So the taser incident outraged me, but what these kids had seen their older brothers, sisters, and in some cases parents go through had conditioned them to be a bit more stoic. It stung a little bit to have this white academic tell me that I couldn't quite relate to a young black man's experience.
所以泰瑟枪事件让我愤怒，但这些孩子看到他们的大哥哥大姐姐，在某些情况下是父母经历过的事情，已经让他们变得更坚忍了。被这个白人学者告知我无法完全体会年轻黑人男性的经历，确实有点刺痛。
I guess when I first approached those boys, a part of me hoped that, like Ibn Ali Miller in the Atlantic City video, I would just roll up out of nowhere and know everything about their world that they know, plus some more. Instead, I was just another adult, taking their time and invading their space.
我想当我第一次接近那些男孩时，我内心一部分希望像大西洋城视频里的伊本·阿里·米勒一样，我能莫名其妙地出现，知道他们世界的一切，外加更多。相反，我只是另一个成年人，占用他们的时间并侵入他们的空间。
Our program was produced today by Neil Drumming and Stephanie Foo. Our staff includes Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dina Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Kimberly Henderson, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, BA Parker, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer for today's show is Brian Reed. Additional help for this rerun from Noor Gill and Stowe Nelson.
我们的节目今天由尼尔·德拉明和斯蒂芬妮·富制作。我们的员工包括苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、迪娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德、金伯利·亨德森、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、大卫·克斯滕鲍姆、塞思·林德、BA·帕克、罗宾·塞米恩、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。今天节目的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德。这次重播的其他帮助来自努尔·吉尔和斯托·尼尔森。
Special thanks today to Frank Nieto, Nalo Hopkinson, Detroit Robinson, Shani Hilton, Nailah Middleton, Steve Kaplan, Stephen Henderson, Lee DeVito, Solange Franklin, Evan Narcisse, Bryce Detroit, Xiomara, and Denmark Vessey. Our website, with this music video to go with the CLPPNG underwater sci-fi song you heard earlier-- also the artist Paul Davey did a piece of original art for today's show-- that's thisamericanlife.org.
今天特别感谢弗兰克·涅托、纳洛·霍普金森、底特律·罗宾逊、沙尼·希尔顿、奈拉·米德尔顿、史蒂夫·卡普兰、斯蒂芬·亨德森、李·德维托、索兰格·富兰克林、埃文·纳西斯、布莱斯·底特律、西奥玛拉和丹麦·维西。我们的网站，有配合您刚才听到的CLPPNG水下科幻歌曲的音乐视频——还有艺术家保罗·戴维为今天的节目创作了一件原创艺术品——那是thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who had the most disappointing latte of his entire life this week. He asked for extra foam, extra cream, but it did not come that way.
《美国生活》由公共广播交流电台PRX交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他本周喝了他一生中最令人失望的拿铁。他要求多加泡沫，多加奶油，但它并没有那样送来。
It was, like, 110% black. It was super black. It was just black.
它就像是110%的黑。它超级黑。它就是黑。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。